so the question was
what are our thoughts on the health
impact of nitrates outside of
performance you know we've talked about
the performance benefits
but this is outside of performance
the question continues seems like there
is a popular consensus that leafy green
nitrates are healthy but nitrates in
meat are linked with cancer through a
nitrate to nitrite to nitrosamine
conversion in the gut is there any good
evidence out there
so there's a really nice review paper by
uh nathan bryan
and the title is inorganic nitrite and
nitrate evidence to support
consideration as dietary nutrients and
nathan brian has done a lot of research
in the night the nitrate space
i've even seen him go so far as to argue
it should be considered a vitamin um you
know so so he's he's done a lot of
really cool nitrate research but they
have a nice little figure where they
talk about the potential benefits which
are cardiovascular in nature
weighed against the potential risks so
on the benefit side
you've got lower blood pressure improved
vascular function lower inflammation
improved exercise capacity improved
mitochondrial function lower
triglycerides less heart attacks less
strokes and these are cardio
cardiovascular benefits presumably of
consuming a diet rich in you know a lot
of plant-based nitrate sources
and then this is all balanced against
the kind of singular risk that you hear
about which is the potential formation
of n nitrosamines which are uh presumed
to be uh carcinogenic that you know
there's there is research that these
compounds can be carcinogenic but the
relationship between dietary nitrate
and cancer is is really complicated and
really messy
so intuitively one might assume that
because these nitrosamines can be
carcinogenic and they can be derived
from nitrate the idea would be that
regardless of nitrate source you know a
high nitrate diet is likely to increase
cancer risk
but the research doesn't really bear
that out and there's actually an
interesting study by song and colleagues
where they found that high nitrate
intake was actually associated with
lower risk of gastric cancer which the
whole nitrosamine idea theoretically
would have a particularly
high degree of relevance to gastric
cancers specifically so nitrate in this
study was actually associated with
reduced risk of gastric cancer but the
consumption of nitrites so not nitrates
but nitrites and
ndma which is a nitrosamine did seem to
be risk factors for cancer within this
particular study
but what's really fascinating when you
dig into some of the epidemiological
evidence assessing this question
it looks like
you're really not going to get any
pushback if you say
plant-derived nitrate sources the fruits
and vegetables that are high in nitrate
are unequivocally healthful additions to
the diet
you're not going to get any pushback uh
the the place where there is some really
interesting debate is whether or not
uh
processed meats
with high nitrate and nitrite content
whether or not those might be
carcinogenic or risk factors for gastric
cancer some research would suggest
suggest yes some would suggest a fairly
neutral effect and so the question is
about uh you know what is the context of
the ingestion of of those particular
nitrate and nitrite products
and when you look at the epidemiological
evidence and some of the mechanistic
evidence it would suggest that
when you're consuming nitrate in
combination with fiber and vitamin c and
other antioxidants
it doesn't seem very likely that you're
going to get a tremendous amount of
nitrosamine formation
and certainly it doesn't seem like these
different plant-based nitrate sources
that contain
fiber and plenty of antioxidants they
simply don't seem to be increasing the
risk of gastric cancers to an
appreciable degree